what's up guys and welcome back to the
Janet and Julian
podcast this episode is brought to you
by bowl and Branch bowl and Branch uh is
a company that gives you luxury bedding
at affordable prices they cut out the
middleman there are no stores delivered
right to your front door you can start a
free trial for 30 days and if you don't
like it they will refund you all your
money and you just send them back but uh
we can speak firsthand these are some of
the most sheets I've ever touched yes
with my hands and my body ever touched
it's amazing go to uh bow and Branch b o
l l and b r n c h Boland branch.com
enter Jenna Julian as a product code and
you get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets yeah you actually put it in one
of your Vlogs of Us opening that box and
touching that I did we were just so
enamored I vlogged about
it it feels like you're at like a a
five-star hotel and you're like oh wait
this is my bed where are you even am I
even right now even yeah it's pretty
great check them out yes thank you bowl
and Branch yep yep yep so uh we are 24
hours removed from the VMAs is has it
been that long yeah I guess it has just
about just about yeah um yeah we did a
long time ago it was podcast number five
where we talked a little bit about um
MMA stuff but also my relatively
unpopular opinion on Kanye West
and uh I wanted to do a followup to that
and I had planned on doing a followup
prior to his speech last night and I'm
glad that I waited yeah because I do
have some things to say about that yeah
and in summary I guess for those of you
that maybe didn't watch that podcast um
I basically just talked about how I feel
like he's very
misunderstood and that it's easy for us
as consumers of some of the things that
he's saying saying we like his music I
think that that's a given most people
agree that he makes good music um but
they have a hard time understanding what
he's saying because he speaks very
passionately and it's easier to just you
know call it ego driil that's coming out
of his mouth and to maybe sit down and
understand it and uh that podcast we
talked about that a bunch yeah and even
some of the feedback in that podcast was
you know uh that I'm sort of taking
someone's words and then doing the worst
thing you can do for someone that's an
egomaniac by saying that he's he's right
or that he's saying good things and he's
doing good things there were a lot of
people that disagreed with what I said
in that podcast which is fine and I
understand your points on where you're
coming from um but I wanted to elaborate
on that podcast one because there was a
really interesting hington Post article
that came out defending Kanye and two
what he said last night at the VMAs yeah
so absolutely honestly that was uh one
of the most I would say you know
personally enlightening discussions
we've had on the podcast I hadn't really
I mean I
know after hearing you talk about Kanye
the way you did after our discussion I
really felt like I got to see a
different side of things and you've 100%
you know made it possible for me to like
you know look at Kanye and and try to
see past what a lot of people stop at a
lot of people see that sometimes he
doesn't know how to um articulate very
well he comes off very intense uh and
and then they stop right there and they
they judge him they put the label right
there but I think if you look a little
further which I learned to do on our
first podcast you uh you're able
to you're intrigued by Kanye a lot more
um I'm really looking forward to this
discussion right now though so okay and
also if we have time at the end I would
also like to talk about my controversial
thoughts on the Kardashian family uh
because I am not a Kardashian hater
whatsoever um yeah that's I would like
to put my two cents in there and also
some people had tweeted at me uh after
the first Kanye podcast that they would
like me to maybe dissect some other
people so if ever there's a person that
maybe you don't understand tell them to
me and yeah leave them in the comments
and i' be more than happy to maybe try
and break down some people good or bad
in my opinion and uh yeah so anyways
let's get into it I mean I did the same
thing that Kanye does which is I got
very excited and most of my notes are
kind of all over the place but uh to
start things off I wanted to talk about
um I forget what year it was but it was
you know 10 years ago at this point uh
the charity for the Hurricane Katrina
when um Kanye was on TV with what's his
face Mike Mike Myers Mike Myers and he
blurted it out on this you know charity
thing where they're asking for money for
Hurricane Katrina and uh Kanye just
blurted it out George Bush doesn't care
about black people and um the article in
the Huffington posts that was written by
um I will find his name give me a second
okay I won't find it um whatever you can
find it Google it it's good um basically
is giving credit to Kanye in hindsight
because Kanye got roasted for saying
that it was not the plan he went off
script he just you know for a moment in
time decided I have a platform right now
and I have something to say and most
people remember that he said George Bush
doesn't care about black people what
most people do not remember him saying
is he had also pointed out that I hate
the way the media portrays us there was
a picture of a black couple and the
caption said that they had just looted a
bunch of food and water and then there
was a picture of a white couple and it
said that they had just they were
carrying supplies basically and you know
they're both carrying bags of what
appears to be food to try and take
shelter and Kanye had Al also along with
saying George Bush doesn't care about
black people had said I I hate the way
that they portray us in the media and he
pointed out something you know that most
people were completely unwilling to
point out at the time while that was
happening you're accusing the president
of racism basically you're accusing a
lot of media Outlets of racism which is
you know very important now in the time
being in the black black lives matter
this is all like at the Forefront of our
Consciousness whereas 10 years ago Kanye
West you know we had this conversation
last time maybe it went about something
something in a way that wasn't the most
polite or respectful he could have found
a different way to say that but he said
it in a way that made us all shut up for
a second and like oh my God shocked us
into listening did he just say that did
he really just say that yeah yeah and um
the article goes on to say that George
Bush had called that the low point of
his presidency yeah you know not 911 or
like a lot of other things he called
Kanye calling him a racist basically is
the worst thing that happened in his
presidency which take that for what it
is you have someone that is freely and
openly speaking their mind on a public
stage and people crucified him for it
yeah you know didn't Obama call him an
idiot like people were really really on
him for that and another thing the
article does is that it says you know
the the people at the time were pissed
they don't know what to do um that that
Mike Myers was kind of upset cuz he
didn't know that Kanye was going to say
that uh everybody was sort of panicked
and flustered and yet now in hindsight
everyone's really really glad that he
said that because Kanye was right and I
think um not to transition yet into the
VMAs but it was very important for
someone on that level to be using an
unfiltered voice about something that
they cared about and I don't think that
you ever necessarily have to be right
that you have to be wrong or anything I
think what's important is that you're
freely and openly speaking your mind on
a stage at a given point of time that is
so admirable and necessary to our
culture all the time forever and ever
and ever and ever and ever yeah uh and
you know that that I'm not bringing it
to the VMAs yet but he did say something
last night very very similar to that and
he's always preached that he will die
for people's rights to be able to say
what they need for for artists to be
able to express themselves even their if
their opinion isn't welcome or popular
he wants to be the force of change in
that department and it it frustrates me
on so many levels seeing the backlash
the internet has had last night of of
his speech because nobody you know he
said some very very real ass things in
that time period yeah it wasn't it
wasn't an Obama speech where it flows
and then you're just standing up and
cheering by the end but it's that's not
Kanye he has so many ideas floating
around his head that he sometimes like
you know doesn't you know get it out
right but he said that last night he
said I want to be I want to be the force
of change so artists can express
themselves I want to be some example for
people to know that they can say
whatever they're feeling and still be on
a huge stage and be popular be famous
and still be able to talk and have an
opinion yeah and and before we get there
to all of that I would just like to
point out that in the last podcast we
talked a lot about how he has great
ideas and it's difficult for people to
understand what he's saying because he
speaks so passionately and the the
biggest way that we get his messages are
through his music because he's more
effective at communicating them in that
way and so it's become our cultural norm
to sort of laugh at this loud clown do
you know what I mean like whenever he
speaks in person it's it's socially
accept for us to laugh at him because
it's Kanye being Kanye it's not as
socially acceptable to say yeah Kanye
said something and it really resonated
with me yeah we we get cuz I'm one of
those people he what he says resonates
with me and you know gotten a lot of
flack for that and I think a lot of
people have in the past by saying you
know I genuinely understand what he's
saying right now and I think that it's
important that we recognize you know in
hindsight what he said about hurricane
Katrina and what he said openly and
blurted out on stage if you know we look
back in time yeah the the author of that
article said you know I don't even think
Kanye would have done what Kanye did
which is important to think about yeah
what would we have done in that
situation we would no one would have
said anything no one would have made any
sort of social commentary and I think
that it's just to say something
overarching right now I think that art
is important I think that artists are
important I think that your job as an
artist if you are an artist in any
capacity it is your job to hold a mirror
up to society and be an honest voice of
truth no matter what no matter how much
it hurts you as a person and I think
when Kanye would I have like a little
bit of a transcript of things I want to
talk about what he touched on last night
but what he was saying when he's you
know basically saying I'm I die I'm
going to die for this art I'm dying for
this art is that he's looking at this
room full of people that are willing to
make art but aren't willing to have the
things that come along with being an
artist that is you know people might
hate you they might boo you in a in a
baseball game people might tell you to
your face oh you're not that bad he's
showing remorse for some of the things
that he's done but still saying you know
what's worth it more than that changing
telling the truth being an honest voice
having no filter he speaking to a room
of people who play a game that he
refuses to play right that's why I think
you know most of us sitting and watching
it from our televisions at home we're
kind of laughing as he takes this
13-minute speech to you know talk to us
about a bunch of things but he's really
giving a big [__] you to everyone in
that room that's like I'm the only one
that's willing to stand up here and tell
the truth all the time and you guys are
you know worrying about who's getting an
award and who's not getting an award and
everyone in here has forgotten what the
point is and that's to hold a mirror up
to ourselves hold a mirror up to society
to be true artists and to speak our mind
and I'm the only one that's using my
[__] mouth and everybody else just
wants to get a contract with [__]
Nike and you know do whatever
endorsements to make as much money as
they can and that they've completely
lost what it is to be an artist and so
you know I'll go through that in a
second but to get this out of the way
off the top I don't care about him
deciding to run for president I don't
know if he's even going to follow up
with that or see that all the way
through that doesn't matter to me what
matters to me is that he has gone so far
to say you know I'm just going to take a
stab at politics [__] until
everyone has to listen to me everyone
has to listen to what I have to say and
by you know claiming that you're going
to run for president is a perfect way
even if I imagine if that you know
happened all the way through that he ran
for anything that he's just going to get
slammed and made fun of and people will
laugh at him but it forces people to
listen to what he has to say yeah it's
not just an interview with sway anymore
it's not just him on Jimmy Kimmel
anymore you have to listen to what I
have to say good or bad yeah I think
you're right I think you kind of nailed
it right there where it's like that's
the point of him saying he's going to
run for president he just wants people
to know that he's going to get his word
out right one way or another it's not
about winning the presidency it's about
getting people to [__] listen but
isn't if you put it in that context in
your brain isn't it you know they take
that I'm willing to die for my art
whatever they take that one liner they
think he's comparing himself to Jesus or
you know just being Kanye to thinking in
an extreme level that makes no sense to
the rest of us but if you think about it
in that way that he's willing to to
commit social suicide in a way to get
his thoughts and his truth into the word
world that really is dying for your art
and your craft and your truth yeah
because you know there's plenty of
studies where uh you look at Social
shaming and that's effect on people um I
forget what that I think her name was
Justine or something when she had
tweeted something along the lines of you
know I'm flying to Africa uh hope I
don't get AIDS good thing I'm white and
it was a joke obviously because no one
in their right mind would say that but
that's sort of reflecting on White
Privilege our culture and she just got
dragged through it was trending on
Twitter people could not wait for her to
get off the plane to tell her to kill
herself a while back but there's been a
lot of really nice articles on that by
describing how much Social shaming is
one of the worst forms of punishment
that you can give give somebody right
like on your little triangle of basic
needs you food shelter water uh um where
am I going the social acceptance you
need acceptance from your peers right
after your basic needs and then you have
whatever self-actualization figuring out
where you fit into the world but it is
so important that people don't feel
shunned by society and that is an
incredibly it's A Primitive form of
punishment it's a terrible thing to feel
nobody wants to feel that and for Kanye
to say that he is willing to do that
he's willing to let people laugh at him
and slam him they know what they're he
knows what they're going to do to him if
he runs for president or if he you know
puts himself out there any more than he
already is he knows what will happen to
him socially that speaks to what how
much he wants to get this across just
his truth just his thoughts I got to say
it's incredibly admirable to me I agree
if I may take a second to say something
um I I got to say it it's
incredibly frustrating and kind of
difficult for me to watch sometimes the
way he is laughed at
um I I identify maybe not on the most
personal level but I identify with
someone who is very very passionate yet
is so kind of hindered by that in a way
of you know not able to communicate well
and it frustrates me to no end and it
does make me really sad like last night
uh watching him the line about getting
booed by 60,000 people and people
laughed in the audience I I really just
that's kind of hard for me to watch
that's not the right way he's not trying
to be perceived but deserves to be
perceived deserves to be welcomed or
recognized or reacted to and you know
it's easy to laugh at and it's easy to
make jokes about his polarizing opinions
and way of talking but but it I got to
say it's one of the most disheartening
things that the moment you try to take
Kanye seriously people are laughing and
I have a tweet that I literally just
retweeted about an hour ago did you see
it no Hank Green tweeted oh I already
favored it three hours ago it says
apparently if you're sincerely thankful
to Kanye West a portion of people will
nonetheless assume that you're being
sarcastic
and he uses the word thankful and I
think that's so so right on point well
did you read his two tweets before that
that he had described why he was
thankful he said that you know I
completely 100% agree with Kanye's
opinion on award shows and that Hank
Green's been offered piles full of money
to make a VidCon based award show and
that he's never wanted to so he's
thankful for his opinion I didn't see
the context that makes it that makes it
better but it's still it's it still
stands that when you do feel like he is
doing some good with his words on the
stage that he gets you're automatically
like taken as oh that's funny good joke
and that's so that's just hard I hate it
and I think it's it's just one of those
things like I I I watched completely in
silence all 15 minutes of however long
his speech was last night I just I just
sat there and watched like I I made a
couple comments like why are people
laughing why are people laughing like
this is making me sad and uncomfortable
that people are laughing right now and
he's up there just like trying so hard
to let you know how big of a middle
finger he's trying to give everyone in
the audience right now for being such
sheep in this industry where nobody
stands up nobody makes it a point to be
listened to or be an individual or have
ideas right 100% And I think that there
are artists that do it delicately they
they give out their opinions here and
there but he is right in the sense that
there is nobody as big as he is that's
willing to use their voice because
there's too much to lose yeah and you
know I think it's going to take you I
don't
know what the result is going to be but
it's going to take a person who who is
very well respected to just one day say
I agree with Kanye guys like everyone
who follows me whether it's a politician
an actor someone massive and someone
respected it's going to take them saying
hey guys this this guy Fu this guy's
[__] saying real [__] right now can
you just shut up stop laughing and
listen to him it's going to take
something like that for people to be
like whoa maybe we should take him
seriously because for some [__]
reason nobody wants to take Kanye
seriously and I understand that it's
easy because there are a lot of reasons
he gives you not to take him seriously
because of the way he conducts himself I
understand that he shoots himself in the
foot sometimes but that doesn't mean
that a person doesn't deserve your
attention or your honest just listen
listen to the person listen to the man
your ears give him just give him that
like and and again going back to the
first podcast where you know we boiled
down that it's easier to laugh off
someone that you perceive as a little
bit loopy doopy like it's easier to just
laugh and say Kanye is being Kanye it's
much harder to sit down and try and
decipher what he's saying Y and I'm just
forever thankful to people that use
their unfiltered voices because I think
that when you're an artist you owe that
to the culture you owe it to us if you
are going to make your living make
creative stuff use your voice use your
brain and don't you know when he talked
about how our kids aren't going to be
owned by Corporate America and
corporations he's basically saying to
everyone and the [__] audience like
[__] you guys and your [__] money and
everything that you're trying to do
right now you're being selfish you're
making yourselves money instead of being
an honest voice for the people listen to
the kids listen to the kids believe in
something bigger than what you are right
yeah um yeah I mean I wrote some other
things about his speech that I can you
know
whatever but I'm I'm I think think that
it's so important that we have someone
on his scale that regardless of whether
or not you agree with him the fact that
he is using his voice so important and
so rare and so uncommon in our society
that we should be really really thankful
that somebody has the [__] balls to
do it yeah I think what you said that
it's easy to laugh off something that
appears crazy is is so right like people
get uncomfortable by by his verocity is
that even a
I don't but his his Fierce presence like
when he gets up in in a place where
people are listening and he doesn't
[__] sit there and make a joke or
make the easy quip that every [__]
one and their mother does at those
stupid incestuous award shows it's just
like he gets up there and he just
literally does whatever is on his brain
at that moment and like the people are
like whoa this is weird let's laugh at
it you know it's like but isn't that
everyone's goal though to be more
present to live more in the Moment Like
that's your goal of life it's people's
goal when they're tweeting out Monday
motivation on Twitter but when it comes
down to it they're not going to [__]
walk the walk when it comes down to when
the mic's in their hand and people are
looking at them and the room is silent
they are going to blend in that's what
everyone does and that's why Kanye is
who is I had read that MTV had given him
a two-minute slot for that acceptance
and after given all of you know his past
and how much he really does just get
dragged through the mud for the things
that he says Let It Go what is the easy
path to do right now stand up there say
thank you act like you're you know so
happy just play the game Kanye
everything's going to be fine what does
he do he Kanye he only does Kanye he
takes the two minutes he knows he has
and he gives it plus double to his
Applause yeah no he took Applause a 12
minute or 13 minute speech yeah so he
doubles the time he knew he had and he
let everyone clap for that amount of
time two two and 12 is not double no d
he doubled the amount of time he had
just got an Applause for that and then
the rest of the time he did what he
wanted y yep yep my notes were um there
were a couple of Publications already
that had made you know quote funny
videos being like cuz I looked on
YouTube cuz I wanted to sort of write
this translation of everything that he
was saying and I could only just looking
at the time of these videos they were 1
minute 1 minute 1 minute 2 minutes and
I'm like well his speech was 1 15
minutes where's his speech and most of
them that said Kanye West's VMA speech
they had made these you know funny edits
of him just going bro bro bro I'm
running for president 2020 and I thought
how [__] disrespectful and what a
joke shame on you for not even giving
him any credit for speaking his mind if
if anything that's a reason why I feel
so passionately about making these
podcasts about talking about Kanye
because it is so important [__] I
will say it to the death that people use
their unfiltered voices in positions of
power or when they have a platform of
people listening so important and how
dare you boil down what he has to say to
just bro bro bro I'm running for
president [__] off [__] you anyways I
will keep going well Jenna we live in
the generation of the easy click and
that's what that is so clickbait
clickbait um I said that the first part
of his speech he was talking about
having remorse for making decisions that
he had in the past you know would I have
worn a leather shirt would I have drank
a half bottle of Hennessy you know all
of this stuff and he sounds almost like
you know he would say you know maybe I
wouldn't have done things the way that I
had yeah but thank you Kanye that you
did first of all that's my response
second of all he goes from there by
saying did I smoke something before I
came here yeah I did yeah I did so he's
basically acknowledging that maybe he
could have remorse for the things that
he's done in the past but he's got
something more important to talk about I
have something more important to talk
about right now yeah I got high before I
came here yeah I just admitted that I
got high before I came here and I want
everyone to [__] listen to me he
talked about how he feels like a
scapegoat which we already talked about
about how everyone else in the room
that's a you know quote unquote artist
is really just trying to be a small
Corporation they're trying to be a
promotional machine they're trying to
make as much money as possible they're
serving them themselves instead of
serving the People by giving them a
voice or holding a mirror up to society
you're you're failing as an artist
you're winning at being selfish yeah
he's angry at the system in which he
became popular which I think is common
and fair but most people don't talk
about that they you know he climbs this
ladder of becoming a musician and once
you get to a certain place in that
ladder he turns around and realizes that
he hates all the [__] games he has to
play just to do what he wants in life
isn't that the only reason you become an
artist because you want to do what you
want to do you want to make what you
want to make but no one ever play no one
ever does that that's that's that's what
he is doing no one ever gets into it
reaches the top and then remembers hey
this is not why I got into it I need to
be myself and not play the game I
playing the game is like the best way to
put it people who say the right thing
and have the right managers telling them
what to say and what not to associate
themselves with and Kanye is just like
that is the worst thing ever that
institution is bad that is what's
creating this environment where everyone
is so terrified to do anything besides
go to award shows and make money and and
do everything that they know is going to
just further them on this path and Kanye
is like um I'm going to go over here and
what is everyone on this path for like
do you see the end everyone's everyone's
got their money and they die like speak
for something believe in something
you know right cuz it is true like you
have to believe that so many people who
get into the Arts or music or whatever
are at one point in their lives
incredibly passionate people and free
and they have an opinion and they
believe in something and it comes out in
their early music so how many people who
make music do you like oh you know their
old [__] is like way more passionate you
know it happens so much because once
they make it big it's like that doesn't
fly anymore their voice get stifled
their voice get stifled people are
telling them different things and it
never ends up being the same person who
got into it and Kanye is just saying
that to everyone like everyone here the
Video Music Awards full of successful
musical artists why are you here right
and I had I had written that um okay I
Well here here's what I wrote he's angry
at the system but in which he became
popular he jumps topic to topic and it's
a little bit hard to follow so people
it's easy for people to again say that
this is ego driil Etc um even though I
think he did a much better job last
night of trying to stay calm through
most of it and at least make some points
that we were easily able to decipher in
the moment without having to go back and
really try and understand I got it I got
the whole thing as he was saying it um I
think he's saying listen to the kids
because he is sick of an outdated
machine because the music industry or
and a lot of entertainment Industries
have become so corporate so like you
know you you have to be X you have to
fit into a certain box he's so angry
with this outdated machine that
everything has become that he keeps
pointing the [__] microphone at the
kids and being like listen to the kids
he's talking to his fellow creators
artists the people that work in in the
music industry he's talking to everyone
and he's talking to us as consumers stop
buying [__] stop listening to
[__] stop feeding into [__]
because we're smarter than that the with
the internet we're a lot smarter than
people give us credit for even if you're
13 years old which I made this point in
my last video you know according to a
lot of religions and science books
you're an adult you know what I mean
listen to the people that are there
buying music they want your truth but
you're not giving it to them so they're
going to settle for your [__] perfume
in your clothing line yeah you know what
I mean yeah [__] piss I'm so I'm
[__] pissed off right now all right
why don't you cool off for a sec we'll
take a break no you good but also take a
quick break just to um shout out our
little sponsor for the week go ahead um
so bowl and Branch guys uh if you are
looking for new bed sheets check them
out go to band branch.com see what
they're about they're much more than uh
just a sheet delivery service they uh
they make it a point to let you know and
also to make public they treat their
workers very fairly uh 250 mil worker
they're all compensated fairly factory
conditions are certified and fair uh a
portion of each uh betting that is
bought goes but yeah goes to fight
underground sex trafficking and that's a
huge huge huge problem today uh that a
lot of people don't think about because
it's not in the first world and it's not
in your face but it exists It is Well
it's not in your face it's not in our
daily lives but it exists and it exists
right around us so um a company that's
willing to you know designate money and
time into fighting uh [__] like that
that's uh that's that's something I
appreciate I agree and everybody's got
to buy some bed sheets so why not put it
towards a good cause that's true there's
been over 9,000 rescued victims just
from um this cause towards fighting it
um 9,300 something which is huge wow
they're putting their money with their
mouth it's band branch.com that's B and
B
ranch.com enter Jenna Julian as your
product code you get 50 bucks off of
your first pair of sheet sheets or set
of sheets rather and uh you can also
just do a free trial guys and for a
whole month you get to sleep on those
sheets and at the end of the month if
you don't like it send it back get all
your money back and it also feels like
you're sleeping in butter like actual
butter well we haven't I mean wonderful
we we what our sheets are how like
pretty pretty old pretty old so we went
from that to like heaven and it felt
like we were sleeping in clouds so
really wellmade stuff thank you to Bow
and branch check them out thank you bowl
and Branch for supporting
us um I mean I think we've said a lot
about Kanye and and a lot about his
speech at the VMAs I for one really
appreciated him again having an
opportunity to just mail it in and you
know finally give up to uh being
misunderstood and you know having people
make fun of him he has every opportunity
every day to wake up and be like you
know what I'm tired I'm tired of telling
the truth when no one will listen to me
I'm tired I want to go to bed you know
what it'll be easy if I just shut my
mouth and play the game and that he
wakes up every [__] day man and
refuses to he has refused to take any
other path other than his own truth
which I think is so important and rare
yeah you know I think I think uh you
notice you notice his impact um on
certain levels that you really have to
pay attention to find but say for last
night big Shawn was accepting an award
for his collaboration with Kanye and he
took a moment to say just just so
everyone knows I would not have any sort
of opportunity that I have right now
without Kanye West like he opened a door
for me that has led to an entire career
has led to all the success for me but he
is why I'm here and I think that was
just like a small Peak into how much
he's respected within the industry like
within the artists and I think so many
people respect him but like even just
saying that much is like like do that no
no one's even you know what I'm saying
like Big Sean took a moment to say thank
you for opening the door for me but I
think a lot of people are almost like
just afraid to associate with Kanye West
by saying something like that like
they're afraid that if they say Hey you
know on an interview at a radio show on
tour uh I'm I'm very inspired by Kanye
West and I always have been and he
continues to be someone that makes me
really proud of be in the music industry
they're afraid that if they say that
they are going to have to deal with [__]
that is attached to Kanye and that's
such insanity and I think a lot of
people in the industry you know do
respect him but not not enough to be
like hey openly associated with him
right they're scared people are scared
scared and and I understand because
Kanye is a scary guy I mean he's he's a
very very strong presence and he doesn't
give a [__] Kanye doesn't scare me at
all but you know what I'm saying like
the mass amounts of people are going to
look at Kanye and say yeah I'm inspired
by him but I'm a little scared to
associate with myself with him right
because they want to to take the easy
path they want to do what he like hates
but at the same time they do they do
appreciate his him and and what he does
in a sense right that's why I think the
again the general consensus is that most
people that enjoy hip-hop music
thoroughly enjoy Kanye's music and then
that's where their opinion
stops even just talking with other
people and when we made that podcast and
I knew that that's it's an unpopular
opinion to have but I just have vast
amounts of respect for Kanye for using
his voice and I think that most people
if they take a hard look at things that
he said and really try and understand
them that he's not you know spewing
garbage he's telling truth bombs and
unfortunately it's difficult for people
to realize that in the present and it's
also difficult for people to realize how
important people speaking freely is yeah
it's like
you have to understand
that like these people who exist in the
world of music who don't on purpose they
don't associate with Kanye West because
they're afraid of the backlash or
they're afraid of the association or
whatever they're afraid of that causing
them to stray off their money-making
business path but the whole idea of
Kanye is not that so either you like him
and you want to associate with him and
you want to tell people you were
inspired by him so you can be on his
team and show people that there is more
than this what we're doing tonight
dressed up in our
tuxes I'm I'm kind of getting lost but
what I'm trying to say is like people
who want to say they appreciate Kanye
but are afraid to be next to him you're
the reason why he is so frustrated like
he that's that's important Julian that
is a very important word that you just
said he is so frustrated at he's been
frustrated for years like do people not
realize that when he does these things
on a larger scale you're speaking openly
to the general public he's already so
frustrated from years of not being
understood why even bother talking why
bother yeah why bother talking to your
feather your fellow artists when I
already know you guys don't get it
you're not willing to stand next to me
to vouch for me to say you understand
what I'm about but you're more than
willing to go online and buy my Yeezys
after you make fun of my [__] fashion
line for years and years and years right
exactly you make fun of me you make fun
of Kim you make fun of everything I'm
about 5 years later 10 years later you
realize that I was telling the truth you
realize that I was making something cool
he he is only you know he's like five 10
years ahead of the rest of the people
and it takes him that long to get credit
for something he said a decade ago how
infuriating hopefully people will look
back on this year's VMAs and say wow
nobody [__] listen to him how
infuriating I would be infuriated I
don't ever blame someone like that for
being
infuriated ever yeah and I would be very
mad you know when you look around
seemingly at your peers and everyone's
like yeah I'd love to make a song with
you but then you know can you do a bunch
of other stuff for me because we're
friends as people no sorry Connie I
can't do that uh my management said it's
bad for the brand can't be associated
with you but I'll have you tweet out our
new song together
please I'm not saying that everyone is
like that he probably a lot of [__]
people are you know are he probably has
plenty of artists that are rid or die
with him um I think it was important
what big Big Sean said about I do too
that was that was I really appreciated
that I don't know too much about Big
Sean other than like just listening to
his music but that that was one thing I
really liked uh that he did for sure and
again my whole point of the first
podcast my whole point of this podcast
discussing him is just how important and
how rare it is for people to have
unfiltered thoughts and ideas on a giant
scale for sure and that regardless of
what comes out of his mouth because he's
speaking his mind we owe it to him to
try and understand yeah because he's
taking a risk and he's being brave huge
risk and he he's taking a risk and he
already knows the consequences are bad
well cuz he's faced them for right he
faces them every day yeah exactly and so
he there's no there's no example of
someone putting their money where their
mouth is more than Kanye does think
about how frustrating that is though
like you know that the consequences of
using your own voice and thoughts is bad
in everyone's mind that would make that
would make you want to shut up and never
use your voice again like I've I've made
plenty of videos where I say something I
speak openly and freely and people do
not like what you had to say
it I understand that feeling of being
like I don't want to speak up ever again
it's like that tallest poppy Australian
you know in a field of poppies you never
want to be the tallest poppy cuz that's
the one that gets clipped and cut off
that's what real told me huh real but I
feel like Kanye has had every
opportunity to decide to shut his mouth
he doesn't and what does that say about
our society though about our culture
that we publicly shame people for using
their voices which is disgusting and
wrong I don't like it I think that
everyone needs to take opportunities to
have a free and open time to speak their
mind to speak their thoughts maybe you
do know that the consequences of it are
bad but it's important that people use
their
voices that's all I care about yeah it's
it's so it's it's so easy to blend in
and lot of people how dare you [__]
people on Twitter and whoever whatever
you're more than entitled to your
opinions but don't ever shame someone
for using their voice that's the
opposite of you know progression we're
not going to get anywhere with people
just staying quiet and playing by the
rules that's not how it works we need
people to speak up y I'm thankful to
someone for speaking up I wish you would
speak up
more so you know even if he doesn't
follow through with running for
president which you know is neither here
or there to me hopefully we see more of
Kanye using his voice because I
appreciate it well yeah I appreciate it
too and I
appreciate being able to talk um about
how much I appreciate someone who is
[__] Brave like Kanye and I
appreciate seeing a tweet from Vlog
Brothers Hank Green talking about how he
is thankful for Kanye and for some
reason that means he's a joke or that
opinion gets laughed at it makes me
happy to see that like you know not that
it ever was a thought in my mind but it
makes me happy to see that we're not the
only ones sitting here saying Thank You
Kanye right agree yeah um to transition
okay because I think you know that's
what I wanted to say about Kanye and um
guys let uh let's be civil but let us
know in the comments your thoughts your
thoughts on last night and where you
stand yeah and if you have arguments
against what I think I understand your
points and I understand why you say and
we'll read the comments we can have a
discussion yeah and please don't feel
like those opinions are not welcome
because they are the only thing that I
ask is that you don't turn it into a
personal attack against anyone else in
the comments doesn't doesn't help anyone
that's not why we're here right um the
next thing that I wanted to talk about
that I we touched like for two seconds
in the in the first Kanye podcast Kim is
Kim and I realized um after talking to a
couple of you know YouTube people Vine
people that I have a relatively
unpopular opinion about the Kardashians
as well so I wanted to share that with
you and if you don't like the
Kardashians you can go ahead and you
know just turn this podcast off but I do
think that it's a theory that I hope you
would want to listen to Because let's
hear it I it took me a little bit to
come to the
realization okay so this is my opinion I
think that Kim Kardashian and the
Kardashian family are sort of the future
of entertainment and I think that they'
have redefined what entertainment is I
think that they have redefined and made
a new path that did exist anymore that
you can be your own brand and you can be
yourself for a living and I think that's
important to those of us that work or
are in the New Media space and without
Kim and without the Kardashians it would
be a vastly different space than it is
now MH and I know this is a lot like
squinting at a painting hoping there's
something there and that it's going to
take me a little bit to get from here to
here you let's go okay so this is what I
wrote it might be a little bit
scatterbrained but this is what I wrote
I feel like the history of entertainment
goes as such right songs stories once we
get some written languages we can have
some stories right it might be on like a
totem pole or some [__] but we have
stories then radio film Television
Internet and the underlying line of all
of that is that most of it has to do
with Humanity it has to do with being a
human the feelings that you feel great
stories are great stories regardless of
when they happened or how they occur but
we like the ones that we can relate to
so you know a story about a caveman
hanging out with the [__] you know
saber-tooth tiger is not really going to
do much for us at this point but you
know at the time it was a banging story
anyways we are infatuated with real
people as a culture I think that that's
what makes sto stories powerful that's
what makes the internet powerful
television powerful anything powerful we
as people are consumed with other people
we want to feel what it's like to be
alive we want to know what exists we're
very curious by nature which is why I
think social media is one of the most
powerful things that there is because it
literally just gives you a look into
someone else's life and the more you
live your life the more I want to know
your life it's [__] intense yeah
anyways TV went from television trying
to be film you know short shorter form
storytelling to reality television which
was considered the trash of television
and still is to many people it's trash
why would I watch this I hate this this
is garbage we've sunk to a new low in
terms of being entertained I
wholeheartedly disagree I think the
reality television was a gigantic step
towards just getting closer to what
people are interested in which is just
human beings and I I think that we will
forever be more and more fascinated with
more raw more real I if if I could live
you know watch you live 24/7 I will now
I have Periscope now I don't even need
internet jump Cuts I can watch you doing
something live it's a vois way of living
but it just feeds our human nature and
that we're genuinely curious as to how
other people live their lives what is
your life like especially if you're in a
unique position like the Kardashians you
have this gigant family you guys are
funny you guys are beautiful you guys
are rich you're entertaining why
wouldn't I be interested in what your
life is why wouldn't I follow you on
Instagram I'm genuinely curious when you
wake up what your life looks like I want
to know I think that if the Kardashians
didn't exist if she wasn't a punching
bag for our culture and Society if we
didn't relentlessly make fun of her and
she didn't relentlessly give everyone
the [__] middle finger and keep doing
whatever she wanted that we would have a
very difficult time as people of the
internet or people that are trying to
make a living out of being themselves if
Kim kardashan hadn't already paved this
path mhm I think that there are plenty
of people on the internet that have you
know refuse to be cheapened you know
we're not Novelties we're not vehicles
for promotion we're not here to just
push something to a bunch of eyeballs
we're here to make cool stuff and do
whatever we want and I think that
there's a lot of people on the internet
that have fought the battles by not just
you know selling us out and selling us
down the river whatever the [__] but Kim
Kardashian has been doing that same
thing on a parallel level on a different
medium she did it through television and
you know say what you want about her sex
tape and whatever and I think that
people like to boil it down to that and
like I said in the last podcast because
we can't fit her talents or what she
does in a box her success is demeaning
to us do you know what I mean because I
can't say Kim Kardashian is this is so
therefore she makes x amount of money or
she you know does this for a living
because I can't understand what you do
for a living the the fact that you are
able to make money off of it is
demeaning to me and everything that I
know it really sort of Tears us down as
people and has to redefine what maybe
success is is it being the most famous
woman in the world because I think
there's an argument there that she
absolutely is is it making millions and
millions of dollars you know some people
would certainly define success as that I
think that there are so many facets to
how she is successful why she is
successful and what she's doing to be
that person and in essence she's just
being herself for a living and if you
look at you know Leave Out All the like
really really really serious musicians
actors whoever in the world those people
that want to do that for a living take
all of the people that are sort of
getting into things for the wrong
reasons they just want people to pay
attention to them etc etc etc or say you
know you're an actor but you [__]
hate it and you wish you could do
something
else she is doing in theory what
everyone could do if if or would do if
if they could if I could be myself for a
living I would because that's [__]
awesome yeah I think um what you said at
the beginning about how oh right there
too about how be I mean when when when
did Kim start to rise in popularity when
do you know what year well it was I
don't know what year but she was friends
with Paris Hilton and so would you say
like 2009 2008 I'm not good at this
because I don't I'm years are starting
to blur together for me okay so it
really took off during keeping with the
Keeping Up with the Kardashians which
which beun after her sex tape and stuff
like that and that had begun Okay we
okay either way whether you know I I
just think it's a very interesting
parallel you drew to what Kim Kardashian
does and has done and continues to do
successfully wildly successfully and the
term being yourself for a living because
in a sense I Define what I do as being
myself for a living right and a lot of
people on the internet like to Pride
themselves that they are unfiltered they
are vloggers they show their life they
do things on Snapchat like they're
basically them and they get paid to be
them in multiple different ways and it's
amazing how you know the internet has
gone from who are these idiots to okay
they're not that bad to holy [__]
they're very talented and they're
changing the game you know it's like
we're not there yet or whatever but it
Kim is like been doing that for years
it's like the way that you put that kind
of lit that bulb up in my brain that Kim
I mean I knew that she was an incredible
business woman and she figured out how
to capitalize on something in in a
absolutely insane way that no one Chris
is an incredible businesswoman either
way the brand that Kim Kardashian has
she's built that you know I got respect
for that but I never have thought of it
in a way of like Kim is being Kim as a
job that is what she does you know I
know she has a reality show but that is
that I think that's an important point
that you just lit up that if people try
to try to put that together in their
brain like all the YouTubers who make
Vlogs of their lives that you watch
they're being thems right well I had
written you know the reason why we keep
searching for new forms of media the
reason why you know people are stopping
to watch their television and they're
seeking things on the Internet is
because media is democratized anyone can
make YouTube videos anyone can tweet you
know if you have a internet connection
whatever that's besides the point it's
democra so that anyone can do it so by
saying that we don't want to be Mass fed
this entertainment anymore because it
doesn't feel genuine to us you know
somewhere along the line as we're
getting more opportunities to be
entertained we're finding regular people
more entertaining than what you're
telling me to be entertained by and the
fact that I can turn on my computer and
anyone can and I know this and I can you
know consume something that hit it's
harder at home with me I can watch
someone you know eat a sandwich I can
watch someone's grocery store haul to me
personally the more mundane your
activity is the more it entertains you
TR [__] p is the most
entertaining person I think I can
imagine because she is so
unapologetically herself and I even
wrote down here that even with vloggers
and things like that we're start and you
know the fake viral videos and that sort
of thing we're starting to get a little
exhausted of you know the the
pre-planned the story lining like some
of it is infiltrating our happy place
the internet is supposed to be this
honest platform where we go to get the
realest form of entertainment that we
can get and you know when we see these
fake things or you know something that
comes to mind are the vloggers Sam and
Nia I think their names are and how they
went through the big controversy
controversy of them you know getting
pregnant and then not being pregnant and
it just felt planned to people and they
weren't appreciative of it that's an
example although I don't know the truth
in that or not but it's an example of us
being skeptical now even of what we're
consuming online and that we're forever
searching for something realer realer
realist until I feel like I'm you know
sitting next to you and if anything I
think it's just going to point us back
into human interaction the only way I'm
know I know I can get a real experience
is if I'm watching you live or I'm
they're live with you yeah but it's
interesting that the trend in in you
know media has been that we're just
searching for something so basic like I
just am curious about you and your life
and it's what I want to look at all day
every day yeah you know what I mean
yep um what else was I going to say
something else something else something
else yes uh okay I had written that it's
easy to chalk up our generation into
being ego driven like you know saying oh
all these kids on the internet they just
open up their computers and it's m me me
all the time me me me and I think that
that's you know that's like saying that
ego or that Kanye West just spews out
ego driven driil yeah I think that
that's an easy way to summarize our gen
generation I think what people making
that point are missing is that we're
actively seeking connections with other
people because that's what what we find
entertaining and that's what we find
meaningful that's resonating with us
we're not opening our computers to feed
our egos we're opening our computer
relationship people to make a connection
with other human beings and you know
when you look at it from the surface it
looks like people are being very vain or
self-consumed and I think that that is
just such an easy backhanded way of you
know fitting us into a box but again
back to back to the Kardashian thing you
can't NE necessarily fit a lot of people
that are making a living on the internet
into a box because we don't know what
you do it goes against everything that
we've been taught in terms of
entertainment you need to be a singer or
a dancer or an actor you need to want to
be a director or you know some [__] like
that otherwise what's your end game I
don't understand cuz they're taking the
path right now what what do you mean you
want to be yourself for a living that's
the stupidest thing I've ever heard but
look at Kim Kardashian and look at I
mean if you you know really expand your
mind mind for a second if you think
about you know all new media in terms of
people maybe being able to make a living
off of just being themselves look at the
the path that she has set for us it's
huge it's enormous it's endless you can
do anything that you want to do yeah you
know if you want to start a clothing
line and you know go [__] have a
reality show or do whatever the [__] you
want for a living you can well the
amount of you know reality shows and
things of the such that have been
created since that endless countless
ever growing right and and I it
certainly wasn't the beginning of
reality television that was a whole it
was the beginning of that type of
reality television she is in my opinion
one of the first people that was able to
take a sort of you know I think within
television it was sort of seen as this
like easy flash in the pan like think of
all the MTV stars that were on the real
world or Survivor or any of these shows
and these networks and you know shows
they use them they use them for their
entertainment value and then we dump
them and forget about them as human
beings it's disgusting to me and she's
the kind of person that said no you guys
are going to find me entertaining until
I'm not entertaining anymore and I don't
care if it just means I'm going to cry
about some [__] I'm going to get married
and you know it's easy to say that she's
Fame hungry money hungry all of those
things are easy what's harder to do is
to understand the greater implications
of what she's doing for the culture of
entertainment M I think that she was one
of the first people in my opinion that
was able to take what was meant to sort
of be quick and fast and easy tolerable
you know you turn on your beta waves and
shut off and your brain doesn't even
have to work sort sort of entertainment
and decided to turn it in turn it into
an Empire of business yeah Empire is
what I was going to say well I like
Honestly though think of all of your
favorite people people on reality shows
in the past that they just you know
they're gone now they they just go back
to their jobs and their lives which is
not a bad thing and good for you if
you're one of those people in have
there's no shame in that but for maybe
some of those people that wanted to
continue doing that for a living but
that wasn't how it worked then yeah you
know now that's happening right before
our eyes yeah yeah oh you're really good
at being you why don't you just do that
for as long as you can
yeah and I don't want to see Kim
Kardashian and movies I don't want her
to make songs I feel like she dabbled in
some stuff because she was getting so
much pressure from people around her to
be good at something before she just
said [__] you guys yeah no
yeah yeah and also her entire family is
now following in her footsteps of being
themselves for a living yeah and how
fantastic is it it's awesome I think
it's pretty [__] fantastic it's
pretty cool coming from a place that I
would say I do something pretty similar
ilar in a way yeah yeah well yeah again
it's like squinting in a painting you
got to sort of really put some dots that
are on opposite sides of the room
together to come to that connection but
I think that it's a a worthy opinion of
acknowledging that I think that maybe
exists you know what I mean for sure
that's fair yeah yeah uh we're tired of
being Mass fed entertainment uh we
Define redefined what's interesting or
truthful for me that's watching people
[__] smell Yankee Candles and tell me
what they smell like I don't give a [__]
man I know it's you in your bedroom it's
real I'm drawn to that thank you that's
all there's no like swoops and like
production there's no story lines
there's no nothing I just watch you in
your room I [__] love it I can't get
enough of it I I will speak for myself
um Honestly though a lot of the a lot of
the times when I am struggling to find
what I would view as interesting to Vlog
about have a a fun cool adventurous Vlog
and I'm frustrated cuz at the end of the
day I just have me around the house
doing boring stuff I'll upload and I'll
be like hey guys sorry it's kind of a
slow Vlog and all you know all the top
comments normally come in as like this
is what we want we want the most boring
sh I just want to know what your life is
about I want to know what your thoughts
are and the more honest you are with me
about that the more I I understand I
don't have to relate to it I don't even
have to like it but I appreciate that
it's an honest opinion well and like you
know um this is kind of straying off I'm
not trying to change the subject but I
would say like three four I don't know
something a long time ago uh I I was you
know I'm always an MMA fan I've been an
MMA fan for a while but I was like
hardcore for a while I was a huge MMA
fan and they started doing these fight
blogs they were called fight blog they
were called blog week and Dana White
would basically have someone follow him
around and basically Vlog fight week for
him and it was the highlight of my life
I loved fight week blog week that's what
he would do at the beginning of the week
you would say guys
it's there's no music it's just but
you're seeing behind the scenes you're
seeing him talk to the fighters after
they got knocked out you're seeing him
talk to someone who's missing weight
you're seeing all this stuff that you
would never see and it's like now that
vlogging is a thing people are seeing
stuff that they would never see in
people's lives you know it's it's very
similar and I I understand that
attraction to it cuz I had it right and
I'm to relate to that point the last
thing that I wrote in my notes for I
told you Julian I'm done WR notes was
why pretend to be something to tell a
story when you can just tell your own
and I think Be Your Own Story yeah and I
think that's what's interesting about
the internet and about you know
consuming that type of media is that we
as consumers of media are finding value
in watching a story unfold long term
like I find it interesting to watch
people grow and change have their
opinions change to just you know be a
person person you're watching it's
something that would never have
existed this is a this is a stretch
right now but I'm going to make a
comparison that cuz I didn't see it the
movie Boyhood didn't they shoot that
over 12 years or something with the cast
growing and actually Chang and it won a
bunch of awards I I think what's
interesting I'm sure it's a wonderful
film I haven't seen it but I think
what's interesting about the internet
and that film like broke grounds and it
it broke a lot of barriers for the film
industry because no one had really made
a film like that over that amount of
time with the same cast I think what's
interesting about the internet is that
we get to see that on a regular basis
you get to see people grow and change
and tell their own stories in their own
words you see progression it it's a
really interesting thing to watch you're
right you're right you're watching like
the Shay Tarts when they do the
Throwbacks exactly you're watching
people tell their own stories how incred
is that and it's and they don't need to
wait however many years for the movie to
be released they get it every day and
the library of their lives live on their
Channel and I think that people that
criticize the internet miss you know
that point they miss a lot of points but
I think most of it boils down to they
don't fully understand why it's
entertaining to be yourself why people
want to watch people being themselves
and why people would want to be
themselves they they boil it down to all
these kids are making a lot of money
it's narcissism it's narcissism foreign
they don't it's feeding their ego um I I
Just Disagree 100% And I think that uh
Kim Kardashian has done a good job in on
a different platform but opening doors
for what is possible for you being
yourself for a living I don't think that
you know a lot of people would choose
her path that people want to be as
famous as she is or do the same things
that she she does that's not what I'm
saying I'm not saying that you should
want to do the things that she does in
her life that's you know your choice or
her choice or anybody's choice I think
it's interesting to see what is possible
because no one has done that before yeah
in my opinion for sure I think that's
fair unpopular opinion puffing I'm with
you I'm the puffing next to you I'm the
puffing right behind you that's
interesting well I feel like I've been
on the same page as you this whole
podcast honestly
well yeah I mean and a lot of it is due
to like you enlightening me you know
like the first Kanye podcast I learned a
lot that I did not know yeah well I mean
I think that's it's an important thing
to have your own opinions I think when
you you know are shown all this stuff in
the media and people tell you how you're
supposed to think about a certain person
or how you're supposed to think about
you know the Kardashians or whatever I
think it's easy to form a a mainstream
opinion and it's it's the group
group think thing too also like you know
for for me I go on Reddit all the time
and today I just didn't because there
were too many Kanye jokes and all this
[__] and I'm just like you know what
[__] it I don't want to do this yeah and
I think we can all appreciate jokes it's
not that
it's laughing it's the group yeah it's
the mob mentality it's the everyone join
in on this big joke that is Kanye West
and I was like no I'm not having that
like it's not it's funny to me to watch
vine you know edits of Kanye yeah sure
that's funny I'll laugh at that but the
bigger picture of the fact that one of
the most popular websites in the entire
world uh is filled with jokes [__]
on Kanye like no thanks good yeah and
and that's sort of why I've had it with
laughing at the Kardashians as well I
think that that's it's I'm not really
laughing and and no one's really going
to tell me to laugh well who's really
laughing I mean the Kardashians are the
ones laughing like they're the ones
going to bed at night pretty happy guess
what I got to do at work today I went on
a yacht in St Barts and hung out with my
my sisters [__] like make fun of
me lip sync on Snapchat all day long and
I'm a baller my name is Kylie yeah
Kylie's a [__] ball she's a [__]
baller and she presented an award last
night and her dogs are [__] adorable
so nor and bamb nor just say her dogs
are Legend IGG they're like Peach and
Kermit but yeah that's that's all that I
wanted to talk about I'm sure in my you
know stream of Consciousness at no point
do but you that I just go blah blah blah
blah onto all of
you but honestly even when I watched
that first Kanye podcast I was like damn
I should have said this I should have
said that I should have had more clear
thoughts but the fact of the matter is
once I get excited about something it's
very difficult for me to like make my
thoughts I think that's something that
everyone kind of experiences but I
Channel your inner Kanye and don't know
what you're saying while you're saying
it well I I don't hope you get your
point
across yeah well you did prepare and I
also I don't think that I'm going to be
alone in thinking that this was a
podcast that um
at the very least was uh was
enlightening you know even if you don't
agree with what we said cuz I felt like
you know well yeah that's that's why I
like conspiracy theories I like
conspiracy theories only because you
don't have to buy into them I just want
to know what other people think tell me
what your thought process is how you got
there it's infinitely there's
undoubtedly going to be people
disagreeing with everything you do but
the point is like just maybe shut your
um mouth not like in a mean way but just
like shut your like the part of your
brain that you're thinking of what to
say and just open your ears for a sec
and like just maybe just try to let new
thoughts in unfiltered Le and that's not
a word but just listen you know and I
think the first the first podcast made
me really excited to come back and do
this podcast and I think it went well I
was obviously excited to hear what you
said and I think a lot of other people
will be um but as always guys leave a
comment let us know your thoughts and um
please we uh we can even do it Part
three like there's never going to be a
shortage of things to talk about when it
comes to Kanye we'll wait a little while
we'll wait till some more stuff happens
yeah maybe in 2020 probably sooner
though probably sooner probably sooner
but um good podcast good podcast good
thought thank you thank you to bowl and
Branch for sponsoring this podcast check
them out please and Branch bow and
branch.com and enter Jenna Julian as
your product code cuz you're a special
person now you have a product code all
right and you get 50 bucks off your
sheets okay thank you bowl branch and uh
we'll see you guys next week for another
podcast bye guys bye bye friends be nice
to each other in the comments or else or
else I'm going come in there and remind
you what your
Ser all right later guys
bye good yeah unplugg you
good yeah can we take a break before we
do the next one
yes
[Music]